you've had the opportunity to work with
plenty of actors and over the course of
your career even heard that you've
auditioned over 26,000 actors during
your time with SVU what makes what makes
a great actor
well great actors like Gene Hackman Nick
Nolte James Woods I've worked with some
pretty the thing about great cinema
actors who certainly is realized in Gene
Hackman he represents is really a
amazing cinematic actor
I mean his performance in the
conversation when the most difficult
things is to play an introvert and he
played that introvert and you sweat in
his brow you knew exactly what he was
going through his amazing performance
and working with him was extraordinary I
think what it is is what what is case in
films he wasn't acting the character he
was the character it wasn't acting it
was being I could ask I could ask him to
do anything
Jane stand on your head and read the
Bible backwards okay because he would do
it exactly the character she had known
he had no new inhibitions about doing
anything I asked me if it sounds extreme
or ridiculous or foolish he'd do it and
he came out brilliant because he was the
person and he needed a we developed a
script like two months in advance he
loved one in the script always other way
so that by the time you went on the set
he had no problems it was an
extraordinary
I remember typically being with him we
were always good friends we both liked
wine and we were shooting in Bangkok and
I said let's go to the oriental toilet
today and have dinner upstairs they got
a great wine list yeah okay we're
talking with us
and I hear the ad saying roll cameras I
said what time should we go done said
speed and I said oh Jane we'll talk
later
actually he just turned from me and he
turned and from that moment
Gene Hackman turned to the colonel gene
how the hell do you do that I mean I've
seen a lot of good I never could believe
that the depth that he would get to now
Nick Nolte knows that so that because I
think that was the worst curse on the
film is you see the actor acting forget
it if you see acting sometimes see if
you see the machinery working it's it's
a killer yep another thing that Nick
Nolte was a great performance to think
that he had was mother I said I said him
think I had effect this is my did say
this no I said see that you're you're
crazy about the woman look this guy's
putting the make on it you're jealous
and a bit irritated and perhaps he's got
a level of anger and what he's doing
laying down sand with the woman you love
and okay now mediocre directors they
have jealousy written on their forehead
yeah it communicates to the audience and
it's a they ain't terrible but Nick was
able to communicate it and put it down
to the right level the right level of
his emotional being that jealousy is at
level four or six inmate at level up
here somewhere because you conceal those
and so you got it but but it was at the
right
I can't tell me the right emotional
temperature yeah and it wasn't obvious
so that's always heartening to the
director when a guy realizes you've
given him an obvious direction and he
makes it real and deep and profound you
know when you do work with actors and
you do see that they are acting and you
can tell that they're acting how do you
poke that out how do you get them out of
that state and so that they are the
character well I try not to hire actors
first of all
we don't have the skills but well you
just have to you I mean good actors
respond to direction you said look don't
make it so obvious it's a simple thing
sometimes you know and or you say get
get give it more edge or give it you
know you're gonna want to do did did in
the rehearsals of course you explored
the emotions you know I like in my films
I always rehearse before the film starts
not not many not many directors like to
do that some do but I I rehearse at
least a week beforehand and sometimes 10
days it's a great thing because first of
all you eliminate any quarrels with the
script which you don't want to do it on
the set Jean have me say not many
headmistress II wouldn't say that but
some actor would say oh this is
ridiculous line and I'm just like you
start rewriting on the set
it's a time killer time is the most
valuable thing in the film you have it
cost about $200 a minute to shoot and so
if your waste five ministers blown
$1,000 yeah so I try to in the
rehearsals it's first of all it
eliminates that the obvious thing of
difficulties for this trip but to them
we just explore the character go deep
into the carrier discuss what we want
weren't worth where this should come out
where this aspect of the character
should emerge and what part of the film
it should you know this whole structure
look at the flow of the character the
horrible word that comes that they use
it serves the arc of the character but
but it's a it's a useful concept because
that is the arc where it starts how it
develops and where it finishes and that
also provides the energy in the
structure of your film so but yes you
just you know you have to find the right
language for every actor no I would
never
a Gene Hackman ever give him a
psychiatric direction you're doing this
because your mother abused you something
I've heard correct to say that to actors
you know and you've never given him that
justice you just screwed up my mind
he likes ballet when I met him he
said to me hot Jeff I only want three
directions from you I said yeah what
about Jean this was our first meeting
faster slower more or less louder softer
faster slower more or less louder sucker
okay of course I didn't ignore it
but to give him the right direction you
know the right language he loved it and
you have to find the right language for
every actor you work with you can't get
some actors love psychiatric do I call
some psychiatric directions others you
know Gina or find it appalling it so
every actor that has a need to find the
right language because you're working
because you don't substantial
relationship with record actors they
house
it's like husband and wife you know
you're into the lot and it won't take
long before you find out what what moves
him what triggers him or her or him and
but to me they know sometimes I've been
approached recently by the solution
company said Koch FeO an actor's
director are you a shooter what are you
an actor's director are you sure I seven
both we're talking about I like to write
the Ender's but I certainly the cameras
the angle which I look at the angle or
the way to wear photograph it is equally
important do both
Oh a lot of actresses mothers don't like
to have direct actors well I'm not one
of those I like working with actors it's
the fun of directing exploring exploring
the scene with them and getting getting
good performances I think that's part of
the job as of directors and I guess
that's the way I can see zeph direction
you